hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca I'm foreigner again and
today we're gonna be talking about how
to get the loot any new event right of
champions how to get the loot the
fastest that everybody can get all the
loot that they want before time runs out
because this is the only limited time
event as always like the video if you do
enjoy subscribe if you're new I covered
the informational site a 400 that being
balanced changes patch notes hero
updates new event details all that stuff
I like to cover on for honor and with
that let's get started so the new event
right of Champions comes with limited
time loot for example an emote called
radiance which is like a lens flare
a new battle outfit color swatches for
characters and a new event only weapons
as shown on screen now these are the
items that are going to be limited time
loot disc this does not include the mask
outfits those are going to stay forever
but are at a discounted price currently
at the moment so that you will not be
able to get those during the event you
can get those at any time that you want
and you don't need to farm this to get
that what the sad part we're getting the
limited time loot though is that it's
only for a limited time as previously
stated you're not guaranteed loot every
game and you may even get loot that you
fer here that you don't even play so
that's why I made this video in the
first place to show you the fastest way
to get the new event right of champions
gear so first up we need is the fastest
game mode all the PvP modes are out
since their actual players and it's
easier to kill bots so now we're left
with P Vai we can't do duel since it's
the only mode you can't get loot in so
it leaves us with two options brawl AI
and tribute AI depending on your
situation if you're playing solo or with
a buddy play brawl AI and if you have a
team of four played tribute I play
mostly brawl AI since I'm alone and my
average times are anywhere from between
two minutes and two minutes and 20
seconds and for tribute the fastest time
I managed to get was a minute and 50 and
the slowest was about 5 minutes but that
was because I was playing with randoms
and not really coordinating with my team
which is why I recommend you have a
minimum of 3 players for tribute AI any
lowering should just be doing brawl
because of being way quicker and way
easier with less people of course and
then your next step is to just get
farming most spots will be level 1 in
two and those bots mostly throw out
heavy attacks don't really know how to
parry and especially won't parry
unblockable z' so just spam as many
unblockable as possible and parry their
attacks to finish run super quick and
easy in about 30 seconds per tribute
just communicate with your team who
getting while offering and who's
guarding what and communicate as if they
were real players and you should be done
in about a minute in 50 seconds or maybe
about two minutes like I stated
previously though you sadly cannot get
Lua from every match as shown on screen
I played a brawl match and got some
limited time loop while my other match I
didn't get anything sadly so the only
way to do this is to just keep grinding
and hopefully you get the reward for the
hero that you play and that guy is going
to be the end of the video just in case
for a quick recap if you're playing
alone or have one partner play brawl AI
and if you have three people or four
people in your group then go to tribute
AI for the fastest time possible that
guy's gonna be end of the video today
guys hope you guys did enjoy that like
today if you did enjoy it really does
help me out subscribe if you're new like
I've said in the beginning of the video
I covered the balance changes tips and
guides for for honor to make everybody a
better player as well as balance changes
patch notes the new hero leaks new event
details all the informational side of
for honor I like to cover my two most
recent videos gonna be on screen if you
guys want to check that out one of the
videos is on the new red of Champions
details everything you need to know to
be caught up on what happened in this
new event like I said it was in the top
right in the eye or you can just click
the video now since the end cards are on
the screen but that guys hope over
yesterday and peace out and enjoy that
free loot